Welcome back everyone
Happy New Year
It looks like Tobey Maguire Spider-Man made a stealth
comeback in the most confusing place possible.
Like, what is going on here?
I took some digging to find out what's going on,
But it seems like it's connected
to the Sony Spider-Man
spin off movies are doing inside the Venom universe.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There is a lot
a lot of Spider-Man related stuff happening this year.
We have three. Three.
Sony Spider-Man
spin off movies set in the Venom Universe
and that MCU friendly neighborhood Spider-Man
TV series, which is coming at the end of the year.
But if it wasn't clear, all the Sony Spider-Man movies
that they've been doing
the last couple of years are all set inside the Venom
Universe.
They're all on the same planet with the exception of
Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man, Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man.
There have been evidence that they might be trying
to tie one of those universes to the Venom universe.
Like.
What if this is all taking place inside
Andrew Garfield?
Spider-Man's universe?
I've done a bunch of videos about that.
Just because there were so many Easter eggs,
especially in that Morbius trailer
before they cut a lot of that stuff from the movies.
So now a lot of that is deleted scenes.
But this is what that morbius post-credits
scene was all about.
It was meant to be happening on that same earth.
That venom takes place on they just last week
we all saw
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
show up in the most surprising place.
And you were all probably just.
This confuses me, like, Wait, what is great to see him
come back.
I would love to see him come back in more places.
But this kind of doesn't make sense
the way they're using the character.
if you miss it, you have no idea what's going on.
Bad Bunny released a new music video
for one of his songs for the New Year in Tobey Maguire.
Spider-Man is featured prominently during like,
This is Sam Raimi's Spider-Man costume running around.
Bad bunny falls off the building, He saves him.
You see him hanging out with them, playing pool,
chilling out in the Spider-Man suit.
There's like a little tag scene at the end where he sits down on the couch and asked him about his love life.
if you don't speak Spanish,
what's happening in that taxi and is basically him
sitting down with bad bunny, ask him,
what's up, my mad man, When is she going to marry you?
Basically asking him about the girl earlier
in the video that he seemed like he was proposing to.
basically asking him about his love life.
losers, bruised, commiserating,
And as cool as it is to see him come back,
this is one of the weirdest places for Sony
to let Tobey Maguire Spider-Man show up.
Like, what is he doing here? How does this happen?
a lot of you had the theory
that this has something to do
with the Sony Spider-Man, ILM, where toe movie.
So in case you forgot, Sony announced
that Bad Bunny was actually going
to star in a Spider-Man movie about El Muerto.
He's a Spider-Man villain
who's only appeared twice in the Spider-Man comics.
So he's like a pretty small villain.
He was essentially a wrestler
who came from a line of wrestlers that passed down
a mystical lucha libre mask
that granted them special powers.
during the early 2000s,
he fought Spider-Man in a wrestling match set up by J.
Jonah Jameson.
Spider-Man defeats him, then winds up helping him
stop people who were trying to kill him.
then he came back during Marvel's
original Civil War event.
But that was about it. Like those two appearances.
Sony was going to do an origin story movie
for his character, explaining
how he got the El Muerto mass from the comics.
And it sounds like he was originally meant to tie
in with that Morbius Post-Credits scene
in the MCU vulture meeting.
Morbius talking about Spider-Man
saying they should put together a new Sinister Six team
inside this Venom universe.
Sony announces the El Muerto movie
early last year, but the whole year went by
without any real updates on it.
Bad Bunny then announces he's doing another big tour
as a bunch of big music projects that he's working on.
And then all of a sudden Sony announces
that they've canceled that El Muerto movie.
Like, yeah, by the way, that's not happening.
Originally,
the movie was set to come out this January, like that's
when they were supposed to actually released.
Maybe we should have been watching it right now.
Basically,
it sounds like they never cracked the script, like
the movie never got that far along in development
before they realized it wasn't going to work in Bad
Bunny just moved on to other music projects
because that's where his big business is.
probably didn't help
that Morbius bombed went full Mormon time.
The outlook for Bardem where movie Kraven Venom three
all more time.
Like all three of those movies coming out this year,
Sony probably not super confident they're going to make
a dump truck of money on everything
probably made them second guess their el muerto plans.
Like why are we doing this character
if we have access to over 900 characters?
if it wasn't clear
because Sony has the Spider-Man rights in the movies,
that gives them access
to over 900 different characters.
Basically, any character that appears in the Spider-Man
comic and there are a lot a lot of Spider-Man comics.
so they're like 899 more popular characters
for them to pick from
if they want to do more spin off movies,
especially if they're trying to tie
all these different movies together in a Sinister
Six franchise,
sort of reinvigorating what they were originally
going to do back during the Andrew Garfield era.
If it wasn't clear way back when Andrew Garfield
was still the main version of Spider-Man,
his Amazing Spider-Man movies were happening.
They were going to do Amazing Spider-Man three.
that original Amazing Spider-Man two Post-Credits
scene with the Sinister
Six was meant to set up a completely separate movie.
It wasn't meant to set up Amazing Spider-Man three.
It was actually supposed to set up
a completely separate Sinister Six movie
that would have turned into a Sinister
Six trilogy with Spider-Man just appearing in it.
And funny enough, while I was making this video,
they dropped like another big daredevil
and Kingpin trailer talking about all the defenders
coming back into the MCU.
Don't worry, I'll do a video about that eventually too.
That's a really big deal,
but it's a completely separate thing.
but the person who created the daredevil Netflix series
like the original Daredevil
Netflix series
actually created the Sinister Six spinoff movie.
He was going to start that big Sinister
Six franchise for Sony.
So what does this have to do with Tobey Maguire?
Spider-Man winding up in a Bad Bunny music video?
I like the theory the Sony let bad Bunny
use Tobey Maguire Spider-Man here in his music video
because it was part of his contract
for the El Muerto movie.
Like Sony canceled the movie for whatever reason.
His contract
just gave him the ability to use that character anyway.
Or less likely, they let him use the character
out of the goodness of their hearts.
Like, when does a major corporation like that
give away rights to $1,000,000,000 character for free?
I think them letting him use Spider-Man
in his music video pretty big music video to it
just recompense for canceling his El muerto movie
like okay,
we canceled your movie,
so we'll let you use the character here briefly.
you have to imagine originally
they would intend to connect El Muerto to all these
other Spider-Man movies like Venom
three Kraven that morbius post-credits scene.
All the other characters in El Muertos post-credits
scene like he meets one of them
in his post-credits scene, teasing a bigger Sinister
six crossover.
there's a small part of me too, that for a while,
when Sony was ramping up their output of all these
Spider-Man spinoff movies, they were literally
just trying to find anything that they could release.
Like, what's a name that we can actually
put on a marquee and actually build a trailer for?
and they just assumed that because it was Spider-Man
related, people would come to see it
like they'll come if we build it.
But in reality, no, like it actually has to be
a good movie we post all the more been time.
Seems like it's a lot of good fun, but in reality
you have to imagine Sony plan
on having full trilogies
for all these different movies, including Morbius.
Jared
Leto even teased that they were going to do a sequel.
It's more Ben time, even though he was also kind of
clowning on himself with the meme.
given what's been going down with the box office
for these B tier comic book movies
the last couple of years.
Most of the lesser tier
stuff has been tanking big time.
It sounds like Sony has also pulled way, way back
on their plans for this Spider-Man spin off universe.
there's a lot of reports
also that they're trying to tie their Venom universe
to Spider-Man four, like Tom Holland's Spider-Man four
in a much bigger way,
I think the ideas are hoping to legitimize their Venom
spinoff movies
even more by putting Tom Holland's Spider-Man
in them way, way more than he's been in the past.
like there was a little crossover during Spider-Man.
No way home and during the Venom, Let there be carnage
Post-Credits scene, but not that much crossover.
Like they didn't actually appear on screen together.
He was just watching him on TV and in Spider-Man,
No way home.
He was just talking about Spider-Man.
But for a little while
I talked about this in my deleted scenes video.
there was actually a version of Spider-Man No Way Home
where Venom was actually going to go to New York City,
like he talked about in the Post-Credits scene,
like maybe I should go to New York City
and talk to that Spider-Man.
he goes to New York City
and winds up fighting in that final battle
at the Statue of Liberty against the other Sinister
Six villains.
that was meant to be their contingency plan
if they didn't
get Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man
or Tobey Maguire Spider-Man.
But they did wind up saying yes to the movie
so early on.
I think they changed their plans a bit, like, okay,
we don't need all these other characters too,
because America.
Chavez was also supposed to be in the movie
for a long time, too.
So they had all these different contingency plans
that were like five different versions of the movie.
If they're Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield stuff
didn't work out.
Tom Holland even joked that when they started
filming the movie, they had absolutely no idea
what the third act was going to be.
So like if you asked him when they started
what he was going to be doing in the third act,
he wouldn't be able to tell you, like,
I haven't got that script yet.
It's changing every single day.
but I am really excited to see Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
come back in an actual, real big way during Avengers
six Secret Wars.
He is supposed to come back during that movie.
He's supposed to come back in a couple of other places.
But I don't know exactly where that's going to be.
Let me know in the comments
if he comes back other places besides Secret wars,
where do you want that to be?
I've done a couple other videos about Spider-Man
for Sam Raimi's
Spider-Man four
because they got so far along in pre-production.
there was a ton of concept art.
There were a ton of costumes made.
There was even music that was done,
even though I don't think Sony is going to do Tobey
Maguire, Spider-Man four,
there has been talk about them doing the story
that would have taken place during that in other movies
Tobey Maguire.
So that was a big thing
when he was working on Spider-Man No Way Home
is that he didn't want the writers of the movie
to expand too much about what he'd been doing
since the events of his Spider-Man
three all those years,
because they could always cover that in future movies.
but if Sony really wants a Spider-Man to appear
in all their spin off movies like these upcoming
Sinister Six movies that they're trying to do,
I don't know that it would be Tobey Maguire
or Andrew Garfield, even though I would love to see
one of them come back for all those movies.
It sounds like they just want to do a couple movies
here and there, like maybe one or two movies would.
They might do.
If Marvel is going to continue doing the MCU,
Tom Holland's Spider-Man movies
is they'll introduce the live action Miles Morales,
and they'll just eventually
use Miles Morales In a lot of these Sinister
Six movies,
I've already done a couple of videos about Sony
talking about their live action Miles Morales movies.
You can click here to learn about that
and about Tom Holland's Spider-Man four
and click here for my Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse teaser trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone
Stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!